good morning John and congratulations on
the release of The Fault in Our Stars
trailer it was fantastic but I have to
say that I'm a little bit upset you
might not even know this but the release
of that trailer happened roughly at the
same time as the release of a short film
that I did with Michael Aranda and I
feel like it's kind of been overshadowed
and nobody's seen it because of all the
tip Theo's mania so I decided that I'm
going to show it to you all right now
without further ado ladies and gentlemen
this is Hank and the tree
yeah huh Michael and I did that as part
of the world builders campaign world
builders is kinda like the project for
awesome except that it's run by authors
instead of youtubers for every $10 you
donate you are entered in a chance to
win one of hundreds of signed books by
dozens of authors and when they reach
certain milestones like in my case
$350,000 people do weird things so check
it out there's a link in the description
now it's wonderful attack at the tree
ease tibias trailers amazing and I've
watched it like 50 times so here are
some other things that I've noticed in
depth review a default nurse stars
trailer Hazel's mom drives a 2012 Honda
Accord a sensible choice Monica drives a
green Mitsubishi Eclipse which is not
what Monica drives in the book the book
she drives a green Ford Thunderbird
Thunderbird she drives a Thunderbird
hazel apparently likes Pink Floyd this
shirt is really old like laser show pink
floyd shirt that you can't get anymore
but I found one on ebay and I bought it
she also likes imagine dragons that
poster is from a show that they did in
Denver I don't know how she got there
and hectic Glo poster her wardrobe is as
expected Chuck Taylors purple bra Cecina
paws on peeps shirt and of course
Augustus is wearing his signature
leather pterodactyl jacket not it's not
made of pterodactyl leather oh that
would be amazing people at the warehouse
just noticed that if you look at it a
certain way it looks like a pterodactyl
important diffuse landmarks in blue the
Anne Frank House of bridge where John
once stared at us the literal Heart of
Jesus and the vaguely pedophilic swing
seeking the butts of children hg on the
ceiling probably stands for hazel grace
but maybe it stands for Hank green you
don't know what's this on the nightstand
a piece of paper what is that do you
think it could be maybe a Venn diagram
John thank you for helping bring
something so cool into the world I'm
extremely excited for you and for me
wanna go see it and it's still five
months away this has got to be a really
freaky time for you like I'm sure you
are super anxious but it is going to be
fantastic congratulations and I'll see
you on Tuesday oh my gosh it's a hank or
fish they're real available for
pre-order at dftba.com and if you want
to get one of these posters you can't
cuz they were only available during the
project for awesome I'm sorry